[Musique]
les moteurs tournent les voitures
chauffer les pneus lors du tour de
formation
c'est la demi-finale de cette 4e manche
du championnat de france de voitures
radiocommandées les bolides à l'échelle
1 8e sur la piste de morphée c'est un
circuit qui est assez rapide
les difficultés c'est les passages de
bosses et le circuit est relié d'être en
largeur ce qu'on trouve actuellement il
est plutôt en profondeur donc en fait on
est obligé de mettre les pilotes sur une
zone surélevée à trois mètres de hauteur
pour qu'il puisse voir la voiture quand
elle est au fond la course dure 30
minutes le pilote réalisant le plus de
tours gagne comme en formule 1 les
stands et les mécaniciens permettent de
ravitailler les véhicules en essence
avec des réglages stratégique
particulier comme alexis clément
vainqueur de cette manche on a beaucoup
travaillé sur les pneus une fois qu'on
avait trouvé notre base de
réglage de voitures scène voilà mes
difficultés de cette pige de la longueur
les deux virages au fond là-bas sont
loin et pour ceux qui n'ont pas
forcément rouler dessus mais je dirais
ça la première difficulté
le morlaisien brice grosjean a connu des
difficultés de moteur il est repêché
dans une course particulière le premier
est qualifié en finale
après quelques minutes brice réussi à
prendre la tête
[Musique]
s'ensuit une bagarre entre les bolides
miniatures avec une victoire finale de
brice et à le commentateur de la course
qui qui commande donc c'est déjà ça
donne un stress plus après le stress de
la course
réussir à garder sa place de premier
s'est pas passé après mof pas une
nouvelle manche du championnat de france
se déroulera à castres du 12 au 14
octobre 2018